- [Narrator] What's the
highest you've ever slept at?
- [Mark] Almost a mile.
When you don't have a fear of heights,
it's not really scary.
It's like being in the craziest tree house
that you could possibly imagine.
- [Narrator] That's Mark Sinnett.
He's a professional rock climber,
and he's talking about sleeping in a tent.
- [Mark] They're called portaledges.
- [Narrator] That's hanging
off the side of a mountain.
He's been climbing for over 30 years,
and his favorite walls to
climb are really, really high.
- [Mark] Alpine big wall
climbing is the pursuit
of scaling the biggest
cliffs on planet earth.
- [Narrator] They take
a few days to summit.
So he has to camp out along the way.
So I want to know what does it feel like
to sleep in a portaledge hanging off
the side of a mountain?
- [Mark] The one thing that's
more or less ever present
in the mountains is when
it can be pretty violent.
You can experience hurricane force winds,
there's also this thing that
we call the Bronco ride.
Wind comes in, hits a cliff,
and it really has nowhere
to go except for up.
Eventually it hits you and your ledge
and it can lift the whole thing off
so you can be suspended
and then, of course,
the ledge like slams into the wall.
You're just thinking about surviving.
- [Narrator] And that
wasn't the worst of it.
- [Mark] The smell in
the ledge is not nice.
You don't change your clothes,
you don't bathe.
It's wet, it's gummy.
- [Narrator] But people love it.
They continue to climb and explore
through all of this punishment
because there's still
that one question left:
How does it feel?
- [Mark] The way it makes you feel
is like a tiny speck of dust.
It's very empowering.
It really is just kind of
like the most spectacular spot
that you can be on planet earth.
(peaceful music)